let's bring in fox news medical
contributor dr nicole sapphire dr
sapphire i want to ask you about that
guidance in just a second but first of
all let's start with the situation in
chicago and i want to quote a very
astute and learned medical professional
on all of this that would be you who
tweeted this morning quote president
biden owes it to the children and
parents of chicago among other places to
condemn publicly the teachers union that
voted to refuse in-person education the
job they are paid to perform
kids first lobby powerhouses last to
quote the band fallout boy doc light
them up up up
uh you know because i have three boys i
happen to know fallout boy and have been
to several of their concerts um but you
know john i'll tell you i woke up and
very very upset to see what is going on
in chicago and you have to know it's not
just chicago it's everywhere else that
teachers unions control the narrative
you have schools closed in newark in
philadelphia we used to joke that the
biggest waste of taxpayer dollars would
come from seat covers at the white house
or some other ridiculous ancillary
service what about the 130 billion
dollars that went through on the
american rescue plan over 5 billion of
which went to those chicago public
schools they've gotten increased
ventilation hundreds of thousands of
mass over 91 percent of teachers and
staff have been vaccinated and yet they
still want more what do they want make
no mistake john at this point it is not
about the children as science and data
continue to show that the safest place
has been in schools there is negligible
transmission in schools as compared to
in the community and in-home
transmission and therefore the teachers
union are using this they're
politicizing their wants and needs and
putting that over children what if other
workers did that what if healthcare
workers what if people who work in the
grocery store said you know what
community transmission is high i'm just
gonna stay home that doesn't work and
these people are putting our children at
jeopardy we have seen a markedly high
rise in suicides attempts overdose
attempts and mental health suffering of
our children this is completely uncalled
for and i want to hear president biden
come out and condemn these people just
like he continues to condemn the
unvaccinated and what we just heard when
he said that this is still a pandemic of
the unvaccinated no that's not true
actually vaccinated and unvaccinated are
causing this virus to continue to
transmit that is the definition of a
pandemic what is what we are seeing are
higher hospitalization rates amongst the
unvaccinated stop condemning and stop
shaming people who are unvaccinated yet
not saying anything when people are
putting our children's life and welfare
at stake all right so the challenge is
thrown down to the president to call out
these unions we'll see if he does now
let me ask you about what jackie
heinrich was just reporting from the
white house that the latest guidance
from the centers for disease control is
if you come down with covet
after five days you can get yourself out
of isolation and quarantined you don't
have to test but if you want to and
you've got access to a test go ahead and
take a test and if you happen to test
positive then quarantine for the
remaining five days of the 10-day
original quarantine
and i'm left
to think what
hey i think most people feel that way
john you know i was listening to that
white house press briefing jackie did an
incredible job at pushing back
i will say that these public health
agencies cdc and even the white house
need to be speaking with purpose and
they need to have clear metrics and
unfortunately that's not what's
happening it's happening it's more
gibberish and all they are doing is
backtracking every time that they get
pushed on something she was asked
whether or not there were external
influences on these decisions and she
said absolutely not but we know that's
not true we know that the lack of
availability to get rapid tests has to
play into effect otherwise you can't say
well you know if you have access to a
test maybe you should test well no
because we know most people don't have
access it needs to be black or white if
after five days to return to work or
retur resume activities you need a
negative test and that's what it should
be and the white house and the
administration needs to do everything
possible to make that happen
all right dr nicole sapphire thanks for
kicking us off today good to see you on
fire as always appreciate it
thanks for having me hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now